just tell us what is the government
advice right now as we uh prepare
ourselves for this record-breaking heat
wave
so our advice is is broadly for people
for themselves to be sensible drink lots
of water stay in the shade we've got a
hot 48 hours coming but also be very
aware of those vulnerable groups who we
think are most likely to succumb to the
heat so that's the very young small
infants
but particularly the elderly often
living alone who may struggle in the
heat and who i think would probably
appreciate the neighborly thing being
done which is for people to go and knock
on their door and just check that
they're okay and they have access to
water you know many of us are used to
traveling overseas for this kind of heat
we don't see it and i haven't seen it
before in this country so we sort of
broadly know what to do and what we're
asking people to do is is just take it
easy in particular there are going to be
disruptions on the trout transport
network um and so where the transport
operators have advised people to avoid
traveling unless they have to obviously
if you're using public transport you
need to bear that in in mind but as i
say we've got a hot 48 hours coming and
we're asking people just to be prepared
and look out for the vulnerable
now your colleague dominic rob was on
with sophie ridge yesterday i mean i'm
sure you would have seen it i know
you're a avid watcher of the political
sunday morning shows and he said that we
ought to enjoy the sunshine and be
resilient enough um i mean is that
sensible advice there is exactly what he
said we ought to enjoy the sunshine and
actually we ought to be silly enough
though through some of the pressures it
will place do you think we should be
enjoying the sunshine
well look if you're lucky enough not to
be working today and you're going to the
beach obviously i know you'll take lots
of sun cream and water and a umbrella
and all those kind of things and be
sensible but we need to recognize that
there are some people who will not cope
well in the heat
and what we want is for everybody to
look out for them
lots of people will go about their lives
perfectly normally so for example we
have said that school should stay open
and kids should go to school that are
very often they're safer in schools and
kids need to learn obviously and schools
can look after them and hydrate them and
keep them nice and uncool but you know
we just need to be sensible we haven't
seen this kind of heat before in the
country uh we need to learn from it and
understand how we operate and adapt our
behavior so we all get through it safely
so with ferocious temperatures she's
still happy for people to go to the
beach and hang out all day in the sun
well some people may wish to um
obviously and it's it'll be cooler at
the coast than it is in the um in the
center of the country particularly in
the midlands and in in london but what
we're saying to people is that they need
to take responsibility for themselves
recognize that this is a really
ferocious heat that we haven't seen in
this country before and adapt their
behavior accordingly now that will
change from person to birth
very elderly people need to understand
that it will be difficult for them in
the heat we all need to understand that
and we want to look out for them right
and particularly small infants uh but i
think you know lots of people understand
that we're just trying to alert people
to the fact that this heat is coming for
the next 48 hours and they need to adapt
their behavior accordingly
i mean we've known this forecast has
been in place for a couple of weeks now
um what mitigation has been put in place
to make sure that schools can stay open
that hospital appointments can be kept
that the trains keep running what's the
government been doing in the lead up to
this to make sure we can kind of live
our lives as much as possible
well obviously as it became clear that
the the weather was going to produce
this record heat and there's a strong
possibility that we'll hit the all-time
record in the next 48 hours we have been
in close contact with all the public
services to make sure that they are as
ready as they can be so guidance being
issued for schools for example so they
can keep children safe and hydrated
making sure that the health service is
aware that it's coming and that they've
got capacity stood up we particularly
look for example at the 999 service
making sure that the 2400 extra staff
we've got in there that extra capacity
will be able to cope so we're sort of
getting everybody stood up and ready for
the next 48 hours and we just need to to
get through that learn from it and then
wait for the cooler air to arrive on
wednesday
so for schools that think that they
won't be able to deal with the
temperatures and the heat that the kids
are facing to think they should close
well we've said that that school should
stay open but that it is a decision for
the local head teacher now there are
some
schools where obviously the building or
for other reasons they may not feel that
they're able to keep the kids nice and
nice and safe and cool and hydrated and
if that is so then obviously it's a
decision for the head teacher but for
the vast majority we believe they should
stay open
okay um you shared a cobra meeting over
the weekend does the prime minister
there
uh he wasn't but it is my job to check
over meetings and i briefed him
yesterday morning at about eight o'clock
personally
i mean we've got a red extreme heat
warning do you not think the prime
minister should perhaps have been at
that meeting
no it's literally my job to chair cobra
i in my department i have the civil
contingency secretariat which is
responsible for coordinating the
response across the whole of government
and that's what we've done in the the
two cobra meetings that we've had and as
i say i briefed the prime minister
yesterday morning at eight o'clock
myself
yeah and he where was he this weekend mr
mothers
i don't know his exact whereabouts so
briefed him i can tell you
he was at checkers having a party
all right oh yes sorry i did read that
in the media yes
there he is
so while the country was preparing for
its worst heat wave in a generation the
prime minister was having a party at
checkers
well i have to tell you having chad
cobra on on saturday and then um uh
briefed the prime minister at 8am on
sunday i did have some of my family
around for lunch in my constituency on
sunday lunchtime as well
i know but you're not prime minister sir
i mean do you think that the prime
minister's just kind of decided you know
he's going to be leaving the job pretty
soon anyway so there's no point in him
paying attention and being part of these
very important meetings
so as i say that's completely unfair we
communicated on on the saturday or
friday as well and then as i say i
briefed him at eight o'clock on on
sunday morning so he's right across this
i think this is a very unfair
characterization of the media um around
this particular issue right it is my job
to chair cobra it's my job to to
coordinate across government and then to
be accountable to him which is exactly
what i did yesterday morning when i
briefed him i mean you know the point
i'm making him smarter he goes to
leadership doesn't it and you would have
thought that when we're facing something
like this the leader of the country
would want to be in the meeting so he
can perhaps lead
our response
well the prime minister has to deal with
lots of things on a daily basis that's
why he like organizing parties at
checkers
that's why he appoints secretaries of
state to deal with those those issues
and as i say we are now well coordinated
we're stood up we're facing a difficult
uh 48 hours possibly and that we
hope and expect that people understand
that it's going to be very hot they'll
look out for the vulnerable and adapt
their behavior so we can all get through
it as safely as possible just a final
thought on this mr martin before we move
on to uh talking about uh the new
leadership race um you said that we are
prepared and we've sort of stood
everyone up
in the event that there is another heat
wave coming do you think that we could
end up drafting in um more assistance
perhaps from the military
well i i can't uh comment on that at the
moment but obviously we keep all our
options open for for where things may go
you know we want to make sure that we
learn from the next 48 hours about how
we can adapt if it does occur again but
look the weather is unpredictable let's
hope it doesn't
okay let's talk about the leadership
race you will have seen the debates uh
friday and last night i mean what do you
make of the way that the candidates are
going at each other
well to be honest with you i mean i
think it's good to have a vigorous
debate uh within any kind of uh
political organization you are our
democracy and reaching the right answers
for the future of our country requires
this kind of challenge and battle of
ideas um and so i was one of the other
socialists
well you know i mean i i generally uh
adhere to the reagan doctrine of not
speaking ill of another conservative i
suppose some people might see
being called a socialist an insult i'm
not sure that's true in the labour party
but there we are um but you know it's
it's i guess it's a sign of a kind of
vigorous battle of ideas and we need to
have that battle so that we can select
the right leader with the right
solutions and then unite behind that
person i mean battle of ideas is one
thing but this is a very public tearing
down of one another and it's not just
about ideas isn't it you could see that
there were points last night but he got
very personal especially between richie
sunak and liz trust i mean what's that
going to do to the party when it tries
to come back together once this is all
over
well look i'm confident uh the
conservative party like any family that
has its internal rows and discussions
sometimes in public um uh that
eventually will come back together again
in the spirit of harmony and love and
unite to win the uh general election you
know it's important that people
recognize that all political parties are
kind of standing coalitions and the
conservative party is the same and a
vigorous exchange of ideas in what is a
challenging time for the country should
be expected when you're talking about
such important issues and the leadership
of a g7 nation if it was just a sort of
polite you know agreement and consensus
across the board there wouldn't be much
point in having the competition at all
so with that in mind then who are you
going to be backing mr malthouse
i haven't declared yet there's still a
long way to go that's why i'm asking you
well i'm going to be listening to the
arguments over the next 24 48 hours and
voting accordingly
i mean who do you think did well last
night wish you sunic
well i think they all did well in their
own way i'm sorry to hedge my bets but
um as i say i i thought they all did
well and we'll have to see how the um
the voting goes today you know in my own
mind i'm kind of keeping a
running tally of the various arguments
and as i approach voting this afternoon
i'll be voting according
okay kit well i do appreciate your time
today uh thank you very much
thanks a lot cheerio